please welcome the director of ID at
Xbox Chris Charla hey everybody so one
of the coolest parts of my job is that I
get to play a lot of games before they
come out I've gotten to play inside and
I can honestly say is a masterpiece this
is one of the best video games I've ever
played and I can't wait for everybody to
get to try it when it launches on jun 29
and to celebrate the launch played Ed's
first game limbo is going to be
available for free to all players on
xbox one starting today pretty cool you
know independent developers have
fundamentally changed the way we play
games this generation bring
unprecedented diversity and fantastic
experiences to players around the world
and with more than 1,000 games in
development for xbox one in Windows
today via the ID at Xbox program we're
really in a golden age let's take a
quick look at some of the great
independent games we're going to be
playing soon
nice time
cuz I holiday
them down
No
ok
she
one take the job
got us out
no grad
you know it has been awesome to see the
incredible creative and commercial
success independent teams are having on
xbox one with multiple million sellers
and hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue going to independent studios one
game that's already broken the million
seller mark is Ark survival evolved from
our friends at studio wild card for
those of you who have already bar arc on
xbox one you're going to be able to play
it a Windows 10 pcs this fall at no
additional cost thanks to Xbox play
anywhere pretty cool yeah so arc
acquired an Xbox game preview it's a
program that enables players to buy and
play games while they're still in
development and offer feedback to the
creators the program has been a huge
success with both players and developers
and we're excited to have a lot more
games coming to Xbox game preview soon
including slime rancher the culling ever
space Daisy and a whole lot more now I'd
like to welcome Guillaume Provost from
compulsion games to come up on stage and
show off the project that's going to be
launching into Xbox game preview next
month gay